okay so we're going to look at the hands
so I don't I don't
ever
enter and then my
hands my
body I'm going to take out the The
Stance and the
body
lowers my hands
one more
time the
body is
lowering my
hands
here body move then you lower your hands
down
body lowers so my my EDI happens and
that's what lowers my
hands my shoulders never come into play
either
up or
down I don't want that so what it feels
like to
me is about how stay here at this level
they don't change their articulation
angle related to my shoulder my
shoulders they stay here and I move my
butt
um second
point and I'll demonstrate it again in
this technique but then I I recommend
using another technique to learn it
here is where I have to cut the X
Line This
Way not that way
because I'm not trying to accelerate him
in the direction he's going
so here's where I
enter against this leg so I'm going to
do it slowly maybe move the camera over
here it goes across this
leg do that same side
again Bo I'm not accelerating him in the
direction he's going I'm not going this
way we
go into his base
here so we'll put the camera
here and we'll take the arms
out and this is what I am I'm getting
this this stop motion is not there
obviously but you'll see me
displace that
leg that's what you're trying to do
because you're generating a Topsy Turvy
effect where you're hitting the two
distal ends to start this Topsy tury
effect different from an acceleration
throw where I just accelerate him so
fast that he opts to take a roll
um that's ferite culture uh we're doing
this top
superv so the two distal ends are made
to rotate around a center that's what
creates it I don't accelerate
one and hope the other one gets to the
top you have a force on the top
and a force on the bottom so you always
create that
so on this
technique and we'll stay at this angle
again is my
kosi is that force on the
bottom that's making his leg come out as
the spirals are making his head come
down so the best place to learn that a
little more
simple is just n from t con so I come
around here and there it is again but
it's on this side on this leg not the
cross lateral leg so I enter if he lets
go I'm going to enter to displace that
leg it's not a
trip in other words I'm not here and
trying to trip him it's actually a
displacement of my base by my base of
his
base so we'll see the two variations an
acceleration throw I throw in the same
direction that he is and I just lower
his hand and then he takes a rooll by
culture in other words he's athletic
enough to just run out of
it cuz there's nothing acting on his
legs just by culture UK keeps his legs
still and then the head gets ahead of
the legs okay and then they do a forward
move but if you're trying to throw
someone you're going to displace the
legs as you do
that so this this technique is the one I
think you should use used to understand
the x pattern be and same for your ukan
it's not so
precarious what you'll notice though is
I have actually have to
have
um Integrity of my own positioning in
order to displace his if I have a bad
place then I kind of bounce off a him
you don't want that you he bounces off
of
you okay so that would be the
ex e
all right I should add that uh if you
use this drill to learn the X patter you
can also work on your uh the fact that
uh my stance lowers my hand not my
shoulder I don't want articulation here
in the shoulder no matter how strong my
lats are I don't want that so when
you're doing this this technique I don't
have my hand go down at the shoulder
it's just here and The Stance is going
to lower the hand as I seek the
base which is very common this stuff to
you know you're up here and you're
like that kind of crazy
okay we we use body
[Music]
unification you want your hand to touch
the mat you have to lower your body
lower your body then your hand gets near
the M okay
not
stuff all right tips on the forward roll
so on the x
pattern if we have this line right here
on the
mat and that would be 12 this is
6:00 on the x
pattern my head is going to
move
rotationally towards
2:00 and my feet will
subsequently
rotate up the circle
towards
10:00 my
Center is going to get projected in
between those two somewhere somewhere
between 10 and two
okay um and we need a new chemi that
allows for that so the head must rotate
in this case with left foot forward the
head must
move towards this side side of the
mat my back foot must move towards that
side of the mat and then when I'm only
throwing
myself my hips will more or less stay on
the 12 to six line okay and then I can
receive the X powder okay the only
difference is there's no um CQ that's
going to take my center and actually
move it
off the 126 line it's just me okay um so
I'll demonstrate first the fedorite rule
which is where my head my center and my
feet pretty much stay on the 12 to six
sline okay uh so you do your your
fedorite roll and you just kind
of roll that way do one more rep
I
roll more or less on the 12 to six
line when someone first learns of the x
pattern and the forward role that
receives that is capable of receiving
the x pattern what they tend to do is
just do the fedorite roll in this case
with left foot forward to
2:00 as they know the head goes that way
but it's not rotating that way way they
just
realign to this and so that if you pay
attention um I'll do it this way towards
the camera
first on the regular fedorite roll on
this 126 line the foot is forward when
someone takes the fedorite roll and
tries to mimic the x pattern receiving
roll they will always turn the foot and
now you just have a new 12 to six line
it's just over here here okay and so if
I'm doing it this way they'll turn the
foot and then they
do a fedorite roll at the angle this is
what you're doing in the video
okay so a drill that I
recommend is to hang out in warrior
pose and let the leg which will
naturally happen
the leg will move to its position you
maintain relationship through an
organized
Center between the head and the foot you
maintain that relationship and the head
will move off okay so I'm going to
demonstrate first warrior pose and allow
my leg to go off which it just does so I
kind of get to this 90 and you just kind
of see that that leg go that
way this is why we actually throw people
this way this is the natural taking of
balance that's what's going to happen
naturally so your drill would be hey hit
hit warrior pose and then Release
Control and allow the leg to do what
it's going to
do okay so I'll demonstrate it one more
time hit Warrior and you'll feel that
leg want to go out let it go
out when you're
ready another difference let me say cuz
when you hit warrior pose it's assume
your chest is up in the fedorite roll
your chest is down it doesn't matter if
I'm doing the fedorite roll and I'm
looking behind me my chest is down it's
clearly not warrior pose
okay
so I'm assuming your chest is open
because I told you to do Warrior clothes
okay and as you start to allow that to
happen you're now going to maintain the
head and foot
relationship and uh and then lower
yourself don't roll from the FR warrior
pose as you're losing your balance
you'll keep incrementally almost like a
hydraulic keep lowering your knee and
try to get it close to the mat okay and
you'll see my head will come around this
way my foot will go that way but my hips
will more or less stay on this line or
even move a little bit to the left of
the line in this case as opposed to this
way with a fedorite roll at the angle
okay so as I'm moving I let that go and
I come out and you see I go this way do
it
again and I'm going to start lowering my
knee so you can see what that looks like
and you can see that my Ru is going to
start slowing me
down not speeding me up like ferite RS
do for
okay the back break
fall the first absolute no no is never
go down on the inside
never never ever that's just got to stop
because we're going to throw you for
real and the instant cannot support the
weight so it's a no
no in most
fedorite
systems UK is accelerated
backwards and UK like that forward Roll
Just opts for a back breakfall they're
not really thr
but we're going to throw you and you
have to come from being in the air to
touching the mat with something that can
actually support that contact and the
InStep is not
it so always the ball the
foot if you're
learning the back rake fall we do this
um we do what you were doing where we
try to accelerate ourselves or have
someone else accelerate
us but we go down on the ball of the
foot so if I am accelerating
myself when I start running
backwards we do
that but I use it to address the fear of
falling not actually how to take the
ukemi for the x
pattern so this is another drill for
let's learn the x pattern receiving back
rle it's on the balls of foot but here's
the drill I recommend if you're by
yourself you're going to send your
Center forward because that's going to
happen in the technique if the
acceleration backwards your Center goes
backwards and you can lower it with your
shoulders in front of your hips that'll
never happen
in the back rake fall so as I am here no
matter how fast I go as I start to go
you see that my shoulders are in front
of my
hips impossible when we throw
you
so shoot your hips
forward as much as you
can contract your Center which you will
have to do in the x pattern receiving
back breall and then find your ball of
your
foot at this point it's almost like a
jump but I'm not going like that because
my Center will come back again my
shoulders will come forward again I have
to squeeze
my pelvic area to contract so that my
Center always stays forward of my
shoulders my shoulders in the same
vertical plane will
never be in front of my hips
never this is one plane shoulders in
another
play they always stay in that
relationship that'll get you
closer
e for